megan the stallion is reacting to the
news that the baby is collaborating with
tory lanez
who is facing charges after allegedly
shooting megan
so tori announced the collaboration on
instagram writing
the baby and tori lane's song and
visuals on the way
hashtag 2021 umbrella
yeah so fans came after the baby for
collaborating with megan's alleged
shooter especially since the baby
has worked with megan several times now
megan tweeted
that ish was old and not cleared crybaby
video dropping soon crybaby is her
own collaboration with the baby from her
debut album
so i take from that tweet that the the
baby tory lanez collaboration was like
recorded before
the shooting happened like that's what i
take from her tweet is that what you
take from that tweet
yeah i don't i don't know and i i it's
it's unusual to see megan vague
right and and i think that that's the
sort of weird thing about this is is
she's
been ever since this happened she was i
know she was vague at the beginning and
didn't want to say too much but then
when she
really opened up and you know lead was
leading the charge
um she's been incredible with everything
with all the information and
and so it seems unusual for it to be
vague so yes maybe i agree with you that
this was probably
done before um but i don't i don't know
i don't know
and the fact that cry the fact that
the fact that the baby hasn't come out
to say anything yet because
if they had a problem with it then you
would think that you would be hearing
from
them as opposed to megan so i i don't
know what to think of this
yeah that's what i find on the eye that
the baby hasn't said anything but yeah
it is tori the one that is promoting the
single
and it takes me back to think about
chris brown right like now everyone
seems to be okay with chris brown
everyone collaborates with chris brown
is that because like rihanna's okay with
chris brown like what do you think the
reason is that the industry
came around the chris brown is it just
time basically
yeah i i think a lot of it yeah i think
you're right i think a lot of it is time
and i think that it takes up a lot of
energy to
ice people out and what it really comes
down to is that it's the music business
and
if you can flip a dollar doing a
collaboration with chris brown
or with tory lanez you take the
opportunity and that's just the way that
it that's just the way that it goes i i
don't i don't know i i
i when when people originally started
you know collaborating with chris brown
it the the blowback wasn't nearly what i
thought it was going to be
and so i think that that sort of paved
the way where
you are allowed to work now keep in mind
that
tory lanez has not had a day in court he
has not had any of that these are all
just
the allegations yeah yeah yeah these are
all just the allegations you know
surrounding that
but i just don't know who would want
that kind of heat i don't know who would
want to be associated with that
given the fact that there are so many
variables and everything is so
is so vague but uh but yeah i've been
wrong before yeah
code says at this point yes artists need
to avoid collaborating with tori yes it
says it took decades for people to stop
messing with r kelly that's true
people collaborate with anyone who'll
get them on the charts that might yeah
it's very true so
i guess it's like what wait a year
before you collaborate with tory lanez i
guess
and the r kelly example is is a great
example
which was it took decades
before people would stop collaborating
with r kelly you know
you could have a conversation with
people about r kelly and
the people would be vicious towards them
but if you were in a club and they put
our kelly on everybody was out there
dancing like there's a
there's always been a disconnect between
the artist and the art
and uh and and when you see it between
artists is when you actually start
questioning it yeah absolutely